it going we know what snake um signifies
symbolizes he's saying under a tree
we're not with the tree what symbolizes
it's got fruit there we know what the
fruit symbolizes
you know adam being um tempted by satan
he's running
he's running um and then he comes in
that's very interesting i want to stop
right here yeah
it's very interesting now this is where
the craft of the matter lies bro and
sisters okay this is where it gets
really really interesting because you've
got the whole now jesus shoe
right okay now to combat the cross
it's got jesus the cross okay on the
cross okay you're bringing jesus and
thanking him
now worshiping satan is outright wrong
he's in cleric
enemy to all of us we all are on the
same side
but satan still wins in the context
where he says okay
you're not going gonna worship me okay i
don't blame you okay don't worship me
however i will make you worship another
creation
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum totally better care to
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are working each other now
if you're a christian i want you to pay
very close attention to this very video
you know because at any we're on the
same side in the context of where as a
muslim i disagree
that this person this rapper is a little
nast or calling a little satan
yeah i'm sorry so to do that it's it's
it's absolutely wrong
and he portrays himself as satan anyways
after killing satan the thing is it's
very outrageous and it's wrong for him
to use a biblical verse
in on a shoe and this whole satanic vibe
and putting blood in there etc and the
666
etc um and i think as questions you guys
have a right
to be offended however from a muslim
point of view i want to come at an angle
where i don't think
you guys uh i think you guys have missed
and this is why as muslims you know we
believe islam came down
what i'm going to do is i want to go to
the video because we have commonalities
with christianity and let's analyze it
i'm not gonna do the whole video just
segments off it's got no music
um and we're going to analyze some
things here so let's get straight into
it and as muslims we can learn something
from this because we're gonna also talk
about the jesus shoe
that's got holy water in it right okay
uh let's get straight into it here we go
yeah okay so as we can see here
um slowly the snake going we know what
snake um signifies symbolizes
he's saying under a tree we're not with
the tree what symbolizes it's got fruit
there we know what the fruit symbolizes
you know adam being um tempted by satan
he's running
he's running um and what happens is he
is then
confronted obviously this is supposed to
be god or something um and then
he comes up that's very interesting i
want to stop right here it's very
interesting that in all of this stuff
they always use this third eye
it's always used now as christians you
guys believe in the antichrist and as
muslims we believe in antichrist as well
which is the
enemy of christ right jesus christ which
we believe was almighty messenger a
prophet from god almighty
who came to worship asked people to
worship god and it came specifically to
children israel it's very interesting
that
they use this whole concept of the third
eye we believe in a concept uh we
believe in
a person called yeah who is the
antichrist who will be defeated and
destroyed by jesus
himself and he's someone that's going to
claim divinity
do miracles as a man uh you know um and
other stuff as well so he's gonna have
certain powers i want you guys to bear
that in mind as christians yeah because
it's very clear here so we can see that
for some reason there's this third i
think always
everywhere you see it so this is not a
myth this is something that there is
being propagated clearly out there
let's carry on so he's being tempted and
he falls for it there you go
and some disgusting stuff happened after
i don't know what exactly says
on this tree i would love to know if
anyone knows but anyway so what's
happening now he's caught by the angels
it looks like there's two angels and
he's been brought in front of
god almighty and he's thrown on the
floor he's chained it seems like
maybe the angels and they're bringing
them into the presence of god
um yeah because later on if we watch for
example if you watch carefully see that
figure there yeah
with the wings yeah there's a constant
christianity about the fallen injury
yeah so here you can see his
you know basically falling into hellfire
yeah um there you go
and he's going to satan himself in his
throat
and breaking satan's neck and taking his
phone basically saying you know i'm
satan
now in a nutshell um you know like i
said we don't believe satan
uh himself uh to be a angel he was at
the ranks of the angels because he was a
righteous servant of god
until he disobeyed god and he was doomed
till the day of judgment and he promised
god to and it's very interesting for you
guys to listen to this he promised god
he asked he asked god
out of god's mercy he asked what he said
allow me respite
till the day of judgement and this
mentioned the quran told that they are
judgment for me to mislead them i'm
going to come to the son of adam
from his left and his right and his
front and his back yeah to misguide them
now this is where the cracks of the mata
lies bro and sisters okay this is where
it gets really really interesting
because you've got the whole now
jesus shoe right okay now to combat that
i think what it is is the very same
company have come with this and a lot of
christians have obviously maybe jumped
on board et cetera where they're like
okay now
you know just to fight the satan off and
it's all six six six um
come with uh this and it's a biblical
verse on it yeah and it's got holy water
from the jordan valley i think
uh uh i'm not really sure here now
this is very ironic in that context
because i didn't think what we muslims
say to our christian brothers and
sisters in humanity
you know and allah tells us that you are
guys are close to us you guys are the
people of the book
right um and you have certain rights and
you can live in islamic lands with us
because you are the people of the book
now what we're trying to say to you guys
in a nutshell guys
is that you've got now the jesus shoe
yeah and let's have a look at the jesus
shoe because it ties together very very
important and very beautifully yeah
so i'm going to play that now now look
at the jesus shoe yeah look carefully
it's got the cross
it's got jesus the cross okay on the
cross okay
and you can see that it's got a drop of
blood there i don't know what there's
maybe the blood sacrifice
okay this whole concept of you know the
black sulphur diaphragm since he's got
mark 14 25 he talks about jesus walking
on water
doing a miracle so i'm going to play
that again though on the background but
guys what i'm trying to say in a
nutshell is this yeah is that
satan's main objective and goal is what
he can get you to commit adultery
it's not that deep he can get you to
drink alcohol
it's not that deep in the context where
it's a major sin yeah but that's not
that's not a knockout blow we don't
believe that's a knockout blow yet and
it's not
yeah he can get you to commit murder
it's not a knockout
he can he can get you to go and steal
it's still not a knockout blow
committing adultery not a blockable
marital sex it's not a knockout blow
doing whatever it may be
it's not however what we
understand what i see from this is that
the main thing god almighty says it look
look even in your scripture
yeah in the biblical scripture even
though we believe that the bible has
been changed and
et cetera that's all discussion on its
own that god almighty
is asking something very clearly even in
second or third commandment he says i
thy god is a i'm a jealous god basically
do not worship god oh god
besides me when somebody came to jesus
and said oh good master what must i do
to gain eternal heaven he said why do
you call me good
there is only one good and that is god
alone yeah
and in the book of acts chapter 2 verse
22 hero israel
yeah jesus of nazareth a man
sent by god to you with miracles
signs and wonders which which god did
among
which god did through him as you
yourselves know
and you are witness to that yeah and in
many places jesus is
always referring to god he's always
talking about the father
he's always always referring to the
father
now if you have a problem with satanism
for example satan you need to ask
yourself a question are you not falling
for his trap
when he is asked the main thing satan
wants from you is to worship another god
that's why in the old testament for
anyone watching other god it was death
penalty captain punishment it was very
harsh
why because it is absolute blasphemy
for god almighty to feed you look after
you give you everything you want and you
go to some other thing
and claim it to be deity and be like
thank you you're bringing jesus and
thanking him
now worshiping satan is outright wrong
he's in cleric
enemy to all of us we all are on the
same side
but satan still wins in the context
where he says okay
you're not going to worship me okay i
don't blame you okay don't worship me
however i will make you worship another
creation
now how does this tie in with the
antichrist don't forget the antichrist
will be a man
he will claim to be good and he will do
miracles because god will give him those
powers to do it
yes and he'll claim divinity who does
that remind you of
yeah somebody who's a man who
you guys claim claims if it is we don't
believe it does yeah you assume he does
does miracles yeah on the day on that
day when the when the antichrist comes
how are you going to differentiate
between jesus and
the antichrist you're not not only that
you are worshiping him
you have a problem with this whole
concept of what little nate nasser
whatever his name is eliot satan yeah
what he did
and you are against his own satanic
worship but you're doing the same thing
you're worshiping jesus as if he's the
one that's created you as if he's the
one who's controller
of the affairs of the world as if he is
your salvation lies on him
you're doing the same thing you're it's
actual idol worship
yeah you are worshiping him so as
christians our muslim from
from your muslim brothers and sisters
what we're telling you guys
is that you're doing the very same thing
you're not worshiping satan
but you're still falling for his trap
where you are not worshiping god alone
that's why
us and i would say the jews you know um
even though jews have certain issues
with attributes of god but
in context what we're seeing is that for
you guys to worship god alone
so here what it is is we single out god
in worship
we worship him alone that's why in the
quran in the quran we recite
i would believe in the shaytan
alhamdulillah
[Music]
[Music]
that is islam in a nutshell and what
we're saying brothers and sisters
is that we worship god alone otherwise
you're doing the same thing you're you
don't want to worship satan
but you're worshiping other than him
which is
jesus not god almighty and i'm going to
leave on that inshallah bronze sisters
this was a video for you guys to
understand you know at the end of the
day shaytan works in many ways and you
are falling for a straight
by not worshiping satan but worshiping
someone else that he
wants you to worship other than god
which is blessed me and going to
if you die upon it knowing it's wrong
it's going to be hellfire
may god protect us and keep us on the
right path if you have any questions
do leave in the comment section until
next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh